The idea of running off
with the circus
or the carnival
was always a very
strong fantasy for me,
so I finally got to do it.
You just lean on your memory.
I remember as a kid
going to sideshows,
those memories are very strong
because it was very scary
and very confusing, and it was
it was like another world
had come to visit us.
Fall on your face.
You can't always control
all the situations you're in,
you can't control
all the aspects of production,
but what you can do
is make whatever you're doing
authentic and and connected.
And if you get outside
of worrying about the result
too much and worrying about,
I mean, I'm conscientious.
I want people
to like the movies,
but there's really a point
where you have to let it go.
You’ve got to stick your neck out,
and sometimes even
flirt with failure.
Whether I do that or not,
I like the idea.